The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RUSS TEDRAKE: So welcome back.
I thought we'd
start today sort of
with a little bit of
reflection, since we
have covered a lot of material.
Even though we've kept
it to simple systems,
we've actually covered
a lot of material,
and we're about to blast
off into some new material.
So I thought, let's
make sure everybody
knows what we've done,
roughly how it fits together,
and where we're going, OK?
So I've been trying to
carry through the course two
main threads.
One of them is sort
of the systems thread.
We start with pendula.
We're getting to
acrobots, cart-poles.
We're going to get more and
more interesting systems.
In parallel, I'm trying to
design this optimal control
thread which tells
you the way I think
you should be solving these.
Along the way, I'm throwing
in lots of puzzle pieces
about partial feedback,
linearization, energy shaping,
things like this.
That's because this is
a hard-thought decision.
I mean, this is a
research class, really.
So I'm doing my very best to
teach all this material to you
as if there's a
textbook on this.
But in fact,
there's no textbook.
So what I've decided
to do roughly
is that, I'm trying to give you
a very clean line of thinking
through the optimal control.
But I do want to keep throwing
in what other people do--
the domain-specific knowledge
about acrobots and cart-poles
and walking as we get to it.
Because I think these
puzzle pieces-- ultimately,
there are things we can't
do with optimal control yet.
My guess is that ideas from
partial feedback linearization
are going to help.
I think ideas from energy
shaping-- these kind of ideas
are going to work together.
So even though those aren't
going to connect up perfectly
in this class, what
I'm hoping to do
is give you all the
pieces of a puzzle
that nobody's
actually solved yet,
give you all the
information I can give you
about this class of
problems so you can go off
and write, well, final
projects that are
cited a hundred thousand times.
OK.
So let me just make
sure that's happening.
So that's a tall order to
sort of carry those threads.
So let's make sure
that's happening.
Maybe I'll even use
a whole board for it.
So I think I've made
no secret of the fact
that I think optimal control
is a sort of defining way
to think about control for even
these very complicated systems.
All right.
So we've got one
thread that we'll
continue-- we'll get deeper and
deeper in about optimal control
methods.
In particular,
we've already talked
about sort of two fundamentally
different approaches
to optimal control.
We've talked about
optimal control
based on the
Hamilton-Jacobi-Bellman
equations, where we talked
about the value function being
described by a nonlinear
partial differential equation.
And then we also talked about
Pontryagin's minimum principle,
which you're probably all
working on right now--
Pontryagin's minimum principle.
These were two sort of
analytical optimal control
approaches, right?
As such, unfortunately,
we only showed
you much of anything
on linear systems
where we can actually solve
those problems analytically.
What were the big differences?
Maybe I-- just to motivate
this so you make-- so make sure
everybody pays attention.
I should also say a few things
about what I hope you get out
of the class, and for instance,
what will be on the midterm
when it comes around.
So I know that we're
throwing lots of ideas out.
If there's one
thing that happens,
one thing that you
should be able to do off
the top of your
head is think about
and talk about how these
different tools that we're
putting out relate to
different problems.
And for instance, if I
were to give you a problem,
you could make some reasonable
guess at what kind of-- what
methods that we've
talked about might be
most suitable for that problem.
The details of how you do a
partial feedback linearization,
I wouldn't expect you to
absorb every piece of that.
I would guide you through
that on a problem,
but with the expectation that
you've worked through it once
on a problem set and sort of
have some ability to do that.
But if there's one thing
I want you to come away
from this class with, I
want you to understand
the suite of tools
we're talking about
and have a sense for what
you'd apply to what problem.
So in the
Hamilton-Jacobi-Bellman
equation, we applied it to--
we applied that--
which, remember,
was this partial
differential equation,
with a hard nonlinearity, which
describes the optimal solution.
I should put stars on here
to be here careful here.
The optimal cost-to-go is
described by that equation.
So one approach
to these things is
to directly try to
compute solutions
to this partial
differential equation.
We did it analytically for the
quadratic regulator problems,
the linear quadratic regulators.
Right.
I didn't actually do it for
the minimum time problem,
because the minimum
time problem,
we know that the optimal
solution in J is actually not--
its gradients are
not well-defined
across the entire-- for all x.
That's the only reason
I didn't do it for that.
But for sort of
smooth problems like
the linear quadratic regulators,
we could use these methods.
Pontryagin is a little
bit more general.
This is the one with
the adjoint equation.
So you defined the
Hamiltonian is here
some cost function plus Lagrange
variable, Lagrange multiplier
times your dynamics.
Pontryagin was more powerful.
In some sense, we
solved harder problems.
We solved, for instance,
the minimum time problem,
for the double
integrator, at least.
The problem with it is
just that it was too local.
The Pontryagin ideas are
based on a gradient statement
of local optimality.
So we said along
some trajectory,
I can verify that if
I change my control
action a little bit
along this trajectory,
my cost is only
going to get worse.
So that's a necessary
condition for optimality.
That's when we can do
a lot of things with--
but it's only going to give me
a local optimality statement.
Are people sort of OK with those
two methods we've been doing?
OK.
From the Hamilton-Jacobi
way of thinking,
we ended up with
our first algorithm.
Right.
And we said that you could
discretize the dynamics,
and in the discrete
dynamics solve
whatever nonlinear problem
you wanted, pretty much.
Right.
And the reason we
could do that is
because these Bellman equations
have this nice form that--
there's a nice recursive form.
It was that J at some x,
n is just the min over u.
This is now-- maybe I should
be very careful when I write it
in discrete, because that's
what we talked about it in min
over actions A, discrete actions
A, S A plus the J of S prime,
where S prime is what
I get for doing this.
OK.
So if you sort of
look at where there's
white space left
on this board, you
might be able to
guess what we're
going to do next, our next
big piece of the puzzle.
We're going to derive our
first set of algorithms
now from the sort of
Pontryagin methods.
And we're going to talk
about some policy search
methods, the most
important class
being of trajectory
optimization.
OK.
Along the way, we've been sort
of following this systems,
we're developing
these systems, right?
In the optimal control, the
analytical optimal control,
we mostly just thought
about double integrators.
But those things could have
applied to any LTI system.
So that's supposed to
be in line with that.
I'll do my best to not move the
board too many times in this.
We moved on to sort
of pendulums, pendula.
And we did the essential things.
This is where I used to sort
of tell you about dynamics.
We talked about nonlinear
dynamics, basins of attraction,
all these things.
And then we did
acrobots and cart-poles,
where we talked about a
lot of interesting ideas.
We talked about
controllability, we
talked about partial
feedback linearization,
and we talked about energy
shaping, even tasks-based.
Lots of ideas in there.
Those ideas are my attempt
to extract the most general.
But the main topics of the sort
of acrobot/cart-pole world,
in acrobots and cart-poles,
people talk about PFL heavily.
They talk energy
shaping, they talk
about these kind of things.
I only presented the
ones that I think
are going to be
useful in general.
But to some extent,
right now you
could think about
these techniques
as being orthogonal to our
main line of thinking, OK?
Now, like I said,
this is a puzzle
that nobody has
the answer to yet.
So actually, what I want
you to be thinking here is,
what can we do with
all these things?
So for instance, I told you that
dynamic programming works well
for low-dimensional systems.
Nonlinear systems, no problem.
Low-dimensional, I can
discretize the space,
I can just run my algorithm,
bup-bup-bup-bup-bup,
compute the optimal
cost-to-go optimal policy.
OK.
But so maybe there's
obvious things to do.
And actually, I think there are
obvious things to think about--
research questions that
you could be thinking about
for your final projects, right?
So for instance, you know,
we used partial feedback
linearization to take--
at least linearize part
of the dynamics of the system.
So this is wild
speculation here,
but let's say I have a
problem that I could then
describe as x1 dot is A1 x1
plus A2 x2 plus Bu then x2 dot
equals f of x1, x2, u, where,
let's say, the dimension of x2
is much, much less
than the dimensions
of the whole original
system, which is what I get--
that's the result. That's the
result I would get from doing
a partial feedback
linearization, where I have,
let's say, for Little Dog,
and I have five degrees
of freedom and four
actuators, that I'd
end up with sort of one very
nonlinear thing and then
a bunch of very linear dynamics
after doing a partial feedback
linearization.
So fantastic research question--
so could I use that
trick and combine it
with dynamic
programming, let's say,
to use dynamic programming
to solve the hard part
and do some sort of LQR
to solve the easy part?
I don't know.
Probably you can.
I bet you can.
And I'd be excited to think
about, with any of you,
you know, what you could do.
But these are the reasons I'm
saying things like PFL, right?
So imagine doing PFL
plus dynamic programming.
I'd bet you could do
higher-dimensional optimization
if you could exploit
tricks like that.
So that'd be a fantastic
sort of research question
to think about for your project.
Are people sort of OK
with how this is going?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are any of those
[INAUDIBLE] dimension that
[INAUDIBLE] convergence or--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good, OK.
So they're not explicitly--
these are not explicitly
targeted to solving
optimal control problem.
So proof of convergence, we
have to define what we mean.
I mean, PFL,
certifiably, provides
this sort of a dynamics.
The energy shaping,
under some conditions,
we showed we could regulate
the energy of our systems.
So there's-- each of these
have their own sort of proofs
and task space.
But most of them
are not directly
aimed at proving that you've
obtained some optimal policy.
AUDIENCE: If you
obtain a kind of policy
which would [INAUDIBLE] goal.
If you have a specific
state that you want to be
in [INAUDIBLE] to get to that,
maybe not optimally but--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good.
So in the energy
shaping I talked about
for the cart-pole--
the energy shaping plus
PFL that I talked about
for the cart-pole and swing-up,
there's a citation in the notes
of a guy that proved that for
a set of parameters-- well,
I'm being a little flippant--
there's a little--
there's a regime where
that's guaranteed to work.
But the general proof that
you'd like to have is not there.
For the acrobot, I know about
even less proof to that.
There is one
particular controller
that we implemented that someone
who took the class implemented
before.
And it does have
a Lyapunov proof
saying it'll get to the top.
But it sort of works by going--
this is an acrobots.
It's going ee-ee-ee-ee.
It's like really unattractive.
So it does something
really stupid.
You wouldn't want to run
it on your real robot,
probably, unless
you're very patient.
But it has a proof
to get to the top.
So these are the trade-offs
that people make.
OK.
Right.
So I hope that sort of--
I hope that was worth doing.
I just wanted to quickly make
sure we're all calibrated.
So let's talk a
minute now about--
so I said that for
the dynamic program
we showed it working
on the pendulum.
I put a big asterisk
saying that there's
discretization errors present.
So even for the pendulum,
it'll solve it lightning fast.
But it's solving the
discretized system, not
the continuous system.
And the optimal
policy you get out
could be different
than the optimal policy
for the continuous system.
OK.
So can you do
dynamic programming
for the acrobot and cart-pole?
That's an obvious question.
So the answer is yes.
People have done it.
My code on the
acrobot and cart-pole
runs in a few seconds.
It's not a problem
of dimensionality.
But the results are not--
of my code-- are not
satisfying because of exactly
the asterisks I put
on the pendulum.
So let's just sort of
evaluate dynamic programming
as we go forward.
So absolutely, the
acrobot and the cart-pole
both have four-dimensional state
space, one-dimensional action
space.
Easily discretized these days.
That's still
low-dimensional enough
that I can actually
bin up the space.
That wasn't true.
When people weer doing it in
the '80s, but it's true today.
OK.
The only real problem
with it is that there's
discretization error.
And essentially, the
discretized dynamics
can be a poor representation
of the continuous dynamics.
If you spend a lot of
time with the acrobot,
you find actually the
acrobot's dynamics are pretty--
are sort of wicked
in a lot of ways.
So actually, spending a lot
more time about it recently--
I mean, even just
sort of making sure
that energy is
conserved when you put
no torque into your system--
this is the basic absolute
thing you do to make sure
you got your
equations of motion--
the acrobot, you have to put
your integration tolerances up
the wazoo to make sure
you conserve energy.
I mean, sort of
[INAUDIBLE] resolution,
the relative tolerance in the
ODE solver in Matlab had to be
something like negative--
1 to the negative
ninth or something
to make this thing
integrate and look
like it had a flat line and
energy as it's just swinging
around with zero torque.
As a consequence, when
you discretize it,
and you run your
optimal control which
converges nicely on the
discretized system, the same--
you can't discretize
it with sort of 10
to the negative ninth precision.
And you'll find that your
discretized system doesn't
conserve energy, for instance.
So that's what's one of
the major shortcomings.
OK.
And so for that reason I'm
going to move on in our--
when we're going to talk
about the optimal control
for the acrobot
and the cart-pole,
we're actually going to
use some other methods.
But I don't want to
move on without seeding
the idea that there are
good ways-- there are
ways to fix this, potentially.
So for instance--
I mean, I think there's
lots of good work
to be done in sort of the
dynamic programming world.
I think there are ideas
from discrete mechanics
and from finite element methods,
where people have thought
a lot about the consequences
of discretizing PDEs and trying
to, for instance, conserve
quantities like energy.
My guess is if someone had
some excitement or experience
with these sort of
methods, I'd bet
the next time I
teach the class I can
say it works for the acrobot.
So this would be a great
final project, yeah?
And publication.
Just do a smarter discretization
of the dynamics, and then
sort of--
so the discrete mechanics
philosophy is that
if you've taken your Lagrangian,
and you've turned it into x dot
equals f of x, u and then you
discretize, then you've done--
you've already--
it's too late.
You've already killed the
beauty of the Lagrangian.
And the discrete
mechanics point of view
is you should discretize
the Lagrangian,
do discretization up here,
and then carry that down
to your equations of motion.
And these sort of discrete
mechanics principles
tend to have much
better properties
and energy conservation
and stuff like that.
We might get to it in our
trajectory optimization family,
but there's a line
of work now called
discrete mechanics and
optimal control that's
been done by Marsden and
all at Caltech that I
think that's my
best lead right now
and how to fix these problems.
OK.
There's another idea out there
for how to fix these problems.
If you judge your problem is
just that your discretization
is bad, another big idea sort of
is variable resolution methods,
which says, let's
stick to our guns,
discretization is
going to work as long
as I have enough resolution.
And because of
computational limitations,
I'm just going to make
sure I put the resolution
in the right places.
So if you discretize the
pendulum or something
like this, when you do
your optimal control
solution on this,
and you find out,
for instance, that when you're
transitioning from this point--
this way, energy
is not conserved.
Or the value function
at these corners
are very, very different.
So it looks like there's
something more going on there,
then let's just add more
resolution there, until--
as much as necessary, sort
of, to capture the dynamics.
There's a nice line of work
in this by Munos and Moore,
the same people I
listed for doing
the barycentric interpolation.
They talked about variable
resolution DP methods.
I think Woody thinks
that this is our--
this is the way to
get value iteration
to work on at least the minimum
time problem for the pendulum
and for the brick--
that if you use the right
splitting criteria--
and that's the big question,
I think, in this work is,
what's the right
splitting criteria--
then you can actually
maybe make serious progress
on these problems.
OK.
So I've given you
a line of thinking
about one class of algorithms
dynamic programming.
We showed how they could apply
to the pendulums and decided
to not show how they don't
quite work beautifully
for the acrobot/cart-pole.
If I build an algorithm
that took overnight to run,
then I think it works.
But they don't run sort of
in real-time in the class,
so let's leave it as
future work to make better
to stay with programming
algorithms for pendula
and acrobots.
And I'm very, very
serious about this.
These are not killer problems.
These are problems that--
I mean, these tools sort of
that you see in the class,
I think, just really haven't
been put together before.
I think that we're
lining up all the tools
to solve these basic problems.
I wish they were
all solved already.
We've just got too many
problems and not enough time.
But I mean, you could solve this
problem in your final project
and make serious
contributions to the field.
This is the state
that the field is in.
OK, good.
So change the world.
Do that for your final
projects, ideally.
That's where we've come from.
Let's start thinking
about-- let me just bite off
today the next big chunk, OK?
You're going to
finish this class
with sort of a Chinese menu of
tools that hopefully will help
you solve all your problems.
OK.
So analytically and
computationally,
there are two major
approaches to solving
these optimal control problems.
Let's even just say
computational optimal--
numerical optimal control.
The first one, like I said, is
you're trying to solve a PDE--
Partial Differential Equation.
The particular name is the
Hamilton-Jacobi-Bellman
equation.
But there is a second approach.
The second approach is policy
search, direct policy search.
Very much still is governed
by the partial differential
equations of optimality.
But the solution
technique is different.
Here's the idea.
Let's design not directly the--
I mean, we've designed
our cost function.
We have our cost function,
we have our dynamics.
Let's not-- let's design a
family of control systems
with a bunch of parameters, OK?
So the policy search
methods define some class
of feedback policies
that you care
about that are parameterized
by some vector alpha.
We define a class of
feedback policies.
And then using the same exact
formulations we used before,
where we used J to represent
the long-term cost of taking
and starting with some initial
condition at some time,
which could be--
this is what I
wrote down before.
Now I'm going to be
even more specific
and say, let's make
J of alpha x0, t.
I'm going to say it's a
function of the parameters.
And I'm going to
say that u is now
the cost of evaluating my
control system with parameters
alpha.
So it's a little
abstract right now,
but let's make it concrete.
So here's a couple of potential
parameterizations, right?
So we talked about
the linear family
of feedback policies,
linear feedback
control with some
big matrix K. Well,
that's a perfectly acceptable
policy parameterization.
If I want to search over the
class of feedback policies
that are linear
feedback policies,
then I could call that
pi of alpha x of t.
It just happens that that
control policy is alpha 1,
alpha 2, alpha n times x.
It's a perfectly reasonable
class of control policies.
Actually, just to
throw it out there,
it's probably a bad
choice, actually.
Because I think people know
that even sort of LQR problems
are not convex in
this parameterization.
I haven't told you how
we're going to solve it yet,
but let me just
throw out the fact
that I think most sort
of serious control people
wouldn't use this as a
representation to search over,
because it turns out the
relationship to performance
based on these parameters
is complicated.
Maybe unnecessarily so.
A much-- a very common
parameterization
is sort of an open
loop control tape,
I'll call it, where
in the simplest form,
let's say u is just is that
a reasonable way to write it?
And every time, I just--
this would be a zero-order hold.
And at any time, I just
find the closest sort
of point in my control tape.
And I'll put-- so I've
got alpha at time 1,
I've got alpha at time 2, alpha
at time 3 just in the tape.
And I just-- as I run my
policy, I ignore state, and just
play out an open-loop tape.
That's a perfectly valid
policy representation.
Maybe a better one would be
something based on splines.
Or even just a smoother
interpolation, maybe that
could be better.
People use things
like neural networks
as policy representations.
There's a lot of work on things
like radial basis functions.
And in general, a lot of sort
of kernel methods in machine
learning you can use sort of--
the point of this
line is you can
use general machine learning
function approximators.
And those tend to be reasonable
policy representations, where
maybe the weights in
the neural network,
even if you don't know
what these things are--
I'm actually going to do a
little bit of an introduction
to function approximators once
we start using them heavily
in class.
But just from seeing the words,
even if you've never used one,
you probably have a
sense that these things
are sort of ways to
represent functions
with a lot of parameters.
And those are perfectly
good candidates.
So the key idea
here is, if we're
willing to parameterize
our control
system with a class
of some parameters,
some finite parameters, then
I can turn my optimal control
problem into a simple
parameter search.
In general now, if
I want to minimize--
the problem is to
minimize over alpha,
let's say J alpha from the
x0 I care about at time 0.
I could describe J
through those equations,
through some Matlab function,
let's say, and just say, find
the minimum of this function.
You can do it with sort
of fmin or various--
any old tools from
nonlinear optimization.
Seem reasonable?
It's important to make sure we
understand why it's different,
OK?
So-- do I still have
this up on the board?
AUDIENCE: Are these [INAUDIBLE]
approximators [INAUDIBLE]
x as input and so y
is output [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE:
Potentially x and time
as an input and u as an output.
You're trying to-- the
function approximators
represent this function, right?
They're mapping which depends
on parameters alpha from x and t
in the general case to u.
in many ways, this is
a very naive approach.
The dynamic programming view
of the world is very beautiful.
We turned our complicated
long-term optimization
of this function into
a recursive form,
where at each step
I only had to think
about my instantaneous
control action.
I did a min over u for that one
step, and that was end to end,
if I could solve my value
function, then that was enough.
I could use my value function to
turn my long-term optimization
into a short-term
optimization, min over u.
Tell me if I need to
say things differently.
In many ways, this
is the dumb approach.
We're not-- we're throwing away
the structure in the problem.
We're just going to directly
search over parameters.
The saving grace is
that I don't have to--
the value function can
turn out to be a hard thing
to represent, especially if--
with dynamic programming,
I can't represented in
10 dimensions, let's say.
So this dumb
approach can actually
work in more
complicated systems.
The only problem is it doesn't
guarantee global optimality.
Like I said, in some ways
it's a very naive approach.
It tends to scale better-- it's
not as sensitive explicitly
to the dimensionality
of the problem.
There's another
nice thing about it,
which there's no explicit
need for discretization, which
I told you was a big problem
in the dynamic programming
thing-- except for there's
discretization potentially
in the ODE sort of integrator.
And that can make--
we do know how to make
that arbitrarily accurate.
The only real killer of these
methods is that they don't--
they're very subject
to local minima.
Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: This
function approximation,
isn't it like discretization
of your state space?
[INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Not necessarily.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
but you essentially--
you don't have full control
[INAUDIBLE] available
[INAUDIBLE].
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's
a good question.
So take the linear
feedback example.
If I have a problem
that I know the--
if I take an LQR problem and
I solve it with policy search,
and I know the feedback
policy should exist
in the class of linear
[INAUDIBLE] things,
then I haven't lost anything
by doing an approximation.
And in general,
these things are--
so radial basic functions
have the feeling
of similar to discretization.
But some of them are much
smoother and much more
continuous than these
hard discretizations.
And the way that
you evaluate them,
which is what's essential, is
you're still going to find--
so if I evaluate the
system by literally
taking my parameters of my
neural network, radial basis
function, whatever,
running this function
without any
discretization, then it'll
give me an accurate
measurement of this function.
Discretization comes
into the-- doesn't
come into the evaluation
of the function.
In dynamic programming,
it's fundamental.
Discretization is right there.
We always operate directly
under discretized system.
So I do think these things
are much closer to being
continuous solvers.
You might say
another disadvantage
is that it doesn't exploit
the recursion that we
know to exist in the problem.
So it sort of feels
like we should
be able to use that
trick more generally.
And a lot of times,
these methods
are going to be the very naive
things which throw them away.
AUDIENCE: You said DP requires
the discretized space?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yep.
That's what I said.
Do you disagree?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
can be [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: Well, then I
would call that an approximate
dynamic programming method,
which is-- these are the--
it depends where
you draw the line.
I'm going to talk about those
in the reinforcement learning
part of the course.
But the thing that
I think people--
I think that we talked about,
which has guaranteed results
for the discrete
system, which is sort
of really dynamic
programming, discretization
is exactly fundamental.
So Alborz is pointing
out that actually there
are people that use
function approximators
in dynamic programming
algorithms.
And we're going to talk
about those in the future.
But they tend to be approximate.
A lot of times, they have weaker
guarantees of convergence.
But we'll talk about
those as they come up.
OK, good.
So now we have a
very simple problem.
We've taken our
optimal control problem
that we've thrown all
kinds of work into.
And we've talked
about the recursion,
we've talked about
the Bellman equation.
And now we just said,
OK, might as well just
think of it, that--
if I run my robot with
three different parameters,
I'm going to get three
different scores.
If I literally take my acrobot
and I make the parameters
all 1, then I'm going
to get some score
for running that policy.
If I change my parameters
so the third parameter is 2,
I'll get a different score.
And I'll get a
different score if I run
a different set of parameters.
I'm just going to run my trial
for, let's say, for 10 seconds
with different
sets of parameters.
And this is going to give
me some landscape, which
is J of alpha.
Now typically in
these problems, I'm
going to be thinking
about optimizing it
from a particular
initial condition.
We can talk about later how--
if you want to get around that.
But this is just some
function J of alpha, right?
So how do we
optimize J of alpha?
Well, there's lots of good ways,
from nonlinear programming,
from nonlinear optimization.
What are some good ways to
find the minimum of J of alpha?
Guess a lot of alphas,
that's one approach.
Pick the smallest one.
OK.
AUDIENCE: You can
form J in a way which
is, you can take [INAUDIBLE]
dynamics smooth then we
can solve [INAUDIBLE].
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK, good.
So let's say I have
an initial guess at J,
and I can actually compute
the derivative of J.
Which I can always do, because
I could do it numerically
if I wanted to, right?
I can just evaluate it a bunch
of times to do it if I had to.
But if I can compute dJ
d alpha, then that'll
tell me that slope.
And I could, for instance, do
gradient descent on that slope.
I could do alpha--
my second alpha that
I'm going to try
is going to be my first alpha.
I try minus some movement in
the direction of the gradient.
I could take this,
estimate the gradient,
and then take a motion that
moves me down the gradient,
make a new update, move down
the gradient, make a new update.
And eventually I'll
get to the minimum
where the gradient
is equal to 0.
How many people have
used gradient descent
before in something?
OK, good.
So nobody actually does
that, I don't think, anymore.
Because we have sort of--
I mean, that's
absolutely the right way
to think about things, and
gradient methods are critical.
But you optimization theory
has gotten pretty good.
So there's another way to do it.
Let's say I had--
I couldn't just-- I not only
compute the first derivative,
but let's say I could compute
the second derivative.
My initial guess here, that
could be the first derivative.
And it could be the
second derivative.
Then what could I do?
AUDIENCE: Fit a parabola to it?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Fit
a parabola to it?
I didn't quite
hear what you said.
Is that what you said, too?
AUDIENCE: Steepest descent.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Absolutely.
Let's fit a quadratic
bowl to it, right?
And actually, the
problem I did right now,
probably the quadratic
bowl is a pretty good match
to the real optimization.
And why not move directly
to this point and then fix--
find a new quadratic bowl and
move directly to that point.
So this would be a
second-order method.
OK.
And so Newton-- a lot of people
call it the Newton method.
Turns out it works just as well
in high-dimensional systems.
If I have a bunch
of alphas, I can
do these second-order methods.
And doing this, in
general, is what
is called sequential
quadratic programming.
Yeah.
And they tend to converge--
there's an additional
cost, potentially,
of computing that
second derivative.
But you can do it by
remembering the past--
the same way you can
remember your-- you
can estimate your gradient by
remembering a couple of samples
and just doing a
numerical gradient.
You can remember a
couple of samples
and compute the-- estimate
the second derivative.
So I'd say probably the most
common method used right now--
how could I say that?
But one of the
very common methods
is to try to compute these
analytically, because--
I'll show you a good
way to compute those.
And then these,
which could be put
could be potentially
more trouble to compute,
we'll just use sort of a
numerical secant method
to collect our
second-order terms,
and then use sequential
quadratic programming.
The thing that makes sequential
quadratic programming
better than sort of the
naive gradient descent
is that it's faster.
But the real thing is that
optimization theory is just
this beautiful thing.
Now I can take constraints
into account very simply.
So let's say I have--
this is sort of a crash
course in optimization theory.
But I think you can say in a few
minutes most of the key ideas.
I mean, to be fair,
most of the lectures
we've had so far, you
could take an entire course
on each one of those lectures.
So pick your favorite,
take another course.
But, you know, I think that's--
I think it's useful to
have the courses that
go over a lot of topics,
and that's what this is.
So what happens if
I now have, if I
want to minimize over
alpha J alpha subject
to some constraint, let's say--
I'll just call it--
I'm running out
of letters here--
A of x equals 0.
We know how to formulate those
with Lagrange multipliers.
But in general,
finding equality,
solving for equalities,
that's just root finding.
That's actually no more
difficult than finding
minimals.
I can use the same
Newton method to find--
to do root finding.
So if I have some constraint,
let's say, alpha--
oh, that was a
really bad choice.
Let's call this something
other than A. Let's just
call it f of alpha, just
so I keep my dimensions
in the same direction here.
OK.
If I want to find--
I'd better make it go through 0.
If I want to find the
zeros of that solution,
I can use the same exact
gradient updates, right?
I can define a zero
crossing if I have
an initial guess at the system.
I take the linearization, its'
going to give me a new guess
for the zero point.
I take the derivative
there, that'll get me close.
That's the Newton
method for root finding.
OK.
So by knowing the gradients,
you could sort of simultaneously
do minimization and root
finding to satisfy constraints.
Long story short, if
you have a problem that
has the form minimize
alpha subject--
some function J of alpha--
it's potentially nonlinear, but
you could take its gradients,
let's say--
subject to linear constraints,
equality constraints, or even
inequality constraints, you
can just hand that these days
to some nice solver--
some sequential quadratic
programming solver.
The one we use these days
in lab is called SNOPT--
Sparse Nonlinear Optimization
Package something,
I don't know.
OK.
So you could start solving
optimal control problems
by literally saying, OK, if I
run this-- just telling it J,
telling it the gradients
of J if you can.
That'll make it faster.
Even if you didn't, you
could just say, here's J,
find me the minimum of
J. You hand it to SNOPT,
it'll go ahead and
do a lot of work
and come up with
the best J, which
is going to be some minima
of this cost function.
There's no guarantee that
it won't find this one.
It's subject to local minima.
But sequential quadratic
programming methods
tend to be better
than gradient methods
in avoiding local minima,
because, for instance,
if I'm here and I estimate
the quadratic bowl, if I just
take bigger steps,
then I tend to jump
over some small local minima
that a gradient method might
get caught in.
So just experimentally,
people know
a lot about how it works
on quadratic programs
if they're actually-- if the
system is actually quadratic.
If it's a nonlinear system
that you're approximating
as quadratic programs, then
they sort of wave their hands,
but it works really
well in practice.
Yeah, OK?
So we have a new way of solving
optimal control problems.
Just write the function down in
a function that SNOPT can call.
Give it a set of
parameters alpha,
it'll churn away and find alpha.
All that's left for
us to do in this class
is figure out the best
way to hand it to SNOPT.
We want to make SNOPT's
computation as effective
as possible.
And there's a lot of
different ways to do it.
So the first way is literally
parameterize your control
system, called SNOPT.
But let's at least be smart
about computing the gradients.
Let's avoid asking
our nonlinear solver
to compute the gradients
for us numerically,
because we can give you those
analytically, exploiting
the structure in the
additive equations,
the additive cost optimal
control equations.
And as it turns out, it's a
direct and clear descendent
from the Pontryagin
minimum principle, OK?
So I'm going to show
you lots of examples
of these things
working on Thursday.
But I thought today,
let's just make
sure that the basic idea of what
we're doing here comes through,
this policy search, and show you
how to compute those gradients.
In fact, let me just tell
you the result first.
I think that works sometimes.
OK, so given J--
I'll just leave off that end
condition for now, the terminal
condition.
The goal is to compute
partial J x0 partial alpha.
My claim is I can compute
that very efficiently
by integrating the
system forward from 0
to t backward from t to 0,
and then I'll get my gradient.
OK.
It integrates the
system forward,
just like you would do it,
run any old simulation.
But while you do it, keep
track of a few key variables.
Similarly, g of x.
It's.
Anybody recognize that equation?
It's written a little
bit different form, but.
AUDIENCE: Filter equation?
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's not a filter.
Well, it could be interpreted as
a filter of something probably,
but.
It's an equation
we've seen before.
AUDIENCE: Adjoint.
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's the adjoint
equation from the Pontryagin.
OK.
Then the gradients--
So I'm done writing for
a second, let's talk.
Do you remember the story
from the Pontryagin?
The derivation sketch
I did, we said that we
had some functional, right?
It was that if we change
our control actions,
we want to make sure that
changing our control actions
at all doesn't increase the--
doesn't change the
constrained minimization of J
subject to the constraints
of the dynamics.
y, in that derivation turned out
to be the Lagrange multipliers
that enforced the constraint.
OK.
What they did was
they put the system--
by making sure that this
equation was satisfied
and this equation
was satisfied, we
made sure that we were
at a stationary point,
at a minima of our functional,
our constrained functional,
of our Lagrange
multiplier equation.
OK.
It's exactly the same
reason we're doing it here.
We now have a functional which
depends on J. This functional
J, the Lagrange
multiplier functional.
And the derivations
are in the notes.
I won't do it again.
By going backwards, by
going-- integrating forward,
we ensure that this
constraint is satisfied.
By integrating
backwards, we solve
for the Lagrange multiplier.
What we're left
with is we can now,
since the gradient with respect
to Lagrange multipliers is 0,
the gradient with respect to
the state equations are 0,
the only thing left is
the gradient with respect
to the parameters alpha.
And it turns out to be this
sort of very simple equation.
So it's this beautiful
thing right that actually--
I hope this is--
it's a lot to write on
the board real quick,
but it's actually a pretty
straightforward algorithm
for computing the
gradients, efficiently
computing the gradients
partial J partial alpha.
All I have to do is
simulate the system forward,
simulate this gradient
equation backwards,
and I'm left with a
direct function alpha, OK?
How many people have worked
with neural networks before?
Yeah?
OK.
Well, this is the
back propagation.
This is the back propagation
algorithm for neural networks.
Turns out to be
exactly the same.
This is the continuous
time form of it.
People have worked
on it and back
prop through time for
recurrent neural networks.
But the exact way-- the
reason the back propagation--
so there was this revolution
in the mid '80s about--
that basically
suddenly, everybody
said neural networks
will solve any problem.
some People still
say that today.
The thing-- the
only thing, really,
that happened, I think,
from my point of view,
is that somebody came up
with an efficient algorithm
for computing the gradients
of the neural network weights
as a function of the
input/output data.
It's exactly this idea that you
can march the system forward
and then integrate backwards.
In that case through
a big neural network,
you had to integrate
these equations backwards.
Being able to compute
those gradients faster
was enough that
the world started
saying neural networks
are going to match
the computational
intelligence of the brain
and solve AI and
all these things.
So it's a little dry, maybe.
But this is potentially
very enabling
to be able to compute
gradients efficiently.
It could change what
problems you can solve.
OK.
Are people OK with the big
picture of where things are?
Yeah?
Good.
So on Thursday, I'm
going to show you,
now that we know how to compute
the gradients efficiently,
I'm going to show
you this put to work,
the intuition of sort
of changing a policy,
searching in policy space
to solve problems like
the acrobot/cart-pole,
and some simpler examples.
And the dumb idea
is, let's just make
it a straight,
nonlinear optimization
problem over alpha.
And I'll try to help
you compare and contrast
the way that works compared
to the dynamic programming.
See you then.